he's going to be the winner of the match
after only three games magnus carlson in
huge trouble here
and you can tell right magnus knows
he's just sitting there waiting for the
hammer to fall
well 45 seconds
not so much time left on the clock and
sometimes you know when you go under a
minute the fog starts to descend and you
start not to see things clearly it's uh
but uh you can just see artemiev on the
camera there he is in focus mode and he
has 28 seconds to come up with an answer
hey so our time has repeated the
position is he panicking or is he just
trying to gain an extra 10 seconds on
the clock so this is the second time
we've seen this position magnus he is in
trouble so he would love a draw so he
brings his king back to where it came
from our 10 minutes bishop steps back
okay this is the second time we've seen
this position and it's a draw i'll tell
you have panics on the brink of victory
what okay let's
look at magnus crawls now he is shaking
his
head getting
lucky here i guess